as promised really enjoy listening him
call games on cbs
at age 37. he was the mvp of
the national football league for gruden
and the oakland raiders who are the las
vegas raiders tonight taking on the
chargers
he's calling the colts and texans this
weekend in week 15 rich gannon here on
the rich island show how are you rich
i am doing great brother and i have to
tell you uh
i'll never forget your your graciousness
and your
hospitable myths and all those wonderful
things when i came into the studio back
in i think 2004 i was still playing and
you were so kind and so patient with me
as i was struggling to
put words together to talk over a uh
you know a highlight reel or you know
some b-roll and you were just great and
i'll never forget that you're uh you're
a guy i look up to in the profession and
you do a great job
and uh anyway your kindness uh certainly
did not go unnoticed back uh in 2004
when i was trying to figure out
after 17 years in a national football
league what should i do with myself well
you know it's i can't believe it's been
that long because you came and spent
some time in nfl network and it was
obvious to me rich that you had a lot to
say and knew how
new knew how to uh say it you know and
um i i really enjoy listening to you
call games you're
you're excellent at it you you call it
like you see it
you know and but that's you know that's
that's who you are and
and that's why i think it works is
you're you're natural and and i
appreciate you saying no rich
it's hard though you know it's amazing
when you get done playing
whether you go to the nfl network
whether you go to cbs or fox they throw
you in a broadcast booth
or they throw you on a set and uh on a
studio show and there's not a lot of
training
and there's not you know there's not a
it's just and you guys are the experts
you guys have the background and
and and so we come in as the experts in
terms of the game but we don't
understand the mechanics of the
telestrator or
you know going to break or coming you
know the timing and the pace i
never forget my first game i ever did i
called the bills buccaneers game yes
in 2005 week one and i think the final
score was like three nothing
and it was three it was it was three
downs and a punt three downs and a pun
and literally
i i just didn't understand the timing
and sean mcmanus
was at cbs along with a guy named tony
petit who's now major league baseball
network
and tony called me on monday after the
game and he said rich
one of two things happened in that game
he said either you don't understand the
pacing and the timing
of television or you had nothing
interesting to say what was it
and i said tony trust me i don't
understand the pacing but i get it
figured out and i've got plenty to say
and that's all you had to tell me the
next week i tell you what i jumped right
in there because there i was waiting
there's all these awkward pauses
like no one ever told me you know how to
do it so anyway
that was a long time ago i think i've
gotten better at my hair
yes you have rich and it all led up to
you calling a game with an owen 13 team
right in front of your face last week uh
that's what it all led to that's what
that's why you're doing it but uh let's
let's start a little bit uh
before we do get into the here and now i
i do want to just go down a little bit
of memory lane of
of your career with you about how you
know you come out of delaware you're a
philly kid by the way the
the same high school of stefanski and
judge
who we just saw go at it i know joe
judge did leave because stefanski beat
him out for a gig
uh to succeed your footsteps in that uh
great prep school
st joe's prep but you wound up in
minnesota right i mean
and and uh after being drafted by the
patriots and then
the only phrase for it i guess is kicked
around a while
trying to find your footing there too
rich correct
i did and absolutely so i came out in 87
and i was actually drafted by the
patriots it was one of the few themes i
never worked out for and they told me
when they
strapped at me it was dick steinberg was
the the general manager and raymond
berry was the head coach and they just
come off that 85 super bowl run right
and so they had tony easton and uh
you know steve brogan and uh a guy named
mike ramsey from ucla so they felt they
were in pretty good shape
and they drafted me and i thought to
myself why would i i don't understand
this and so they told me they want to
find the best position for me when you
tell a quarterback
you know who's 21 years old coming out
of college they want to find the best
position for you i thought to myself
there's zero chance i could go to
training camp and make the team as a
defensive backers running back so
i was accepted to law school my dad was
an attorney i was going to go to law
school and then six days later
i got traded to the minnesota vikings
and that's i wasn't really ready to play
coming out of delaware it took me a
couple years to watch and learn behind
tommy kramer and wade wilson a couple
characters but
i finally got my chance and you know i
kind of bounced around a little bit and
then i got traded to the redskins and
then finally i landed in kansas city
where
i after seven years i got with some
really good coaches marty schottenheimer
and two coaches two assistant coaches
paul hackett
who had a great long career as a nfl
coordinator was a head coach at ufc and
a couple other places but
mike mccarthy was my quarterback coach
rich and i'll tell you
that's really where my game began to
take off he was a phenomenal teacher
and very patient with me even though i
was a seven year veteran
and then so okay i want to put a pin in
that for a moment
then you wound up in in in oakland and
uh what happened there what was what was
the magic sauce there
for you uh was it gruden plus what what
was it
for you rich there's a great clip on nfl
films with
with dick vermeo on the sidelines and he
grabs a hold of ron jaworski he was
struggling at the time and he said i'll
never i'm not going to yank you you're
my guy
and i talked to joel's about that later
and how much that meant to him just just
to know that somebody believed in him
i never really had that until i got to
oakland john gruden basically
stuck his neck out they got rid of jeff
george they owed him a lot of money
and he was convinced that i was the guy
that could come in and i never really at
that point my career you know i
started some games and i had some
success in kansas city but i wasn't the
primary starter so he really
he really believed in me enough to go to
al davis and try and convince
al davis to hire this you know backup
quarterback this kind of journeyman from
the chiefs and i went in there and i
thought to myself at that point
i'd made some good money i had a good
contract and i thought to myself it
doesn't matter
i i i'm gonna do what i know is right
i'm gonna i'm just gonna be honest and
truthful and
john and i were just you know birds of a
feather we just hit it off i mean the
system was the same we were
you know cut the same cloth i mean we
just believed in it the same way and
we just were passionate about it and
we're just going to speak our mind i
i didn't make a lot of friends in
oakland my first couple years because
i was just i was hell-bent on getting
things right and there was a lack of
there was a real
lack of leadership there was a lack of
clarity there's a lack of
uh it just it was a dysfunctional
environment guys didn't care
guys didn't work at it and so eventually
we got rid of those guys we started
bringing in some really good players you
know rob woodson and
john perella and jerry rice and trace
armstrong and
you know i could go on wrong just really
guys that cared about football they were
real professionals and it really began
to make a difference not only in the
field
but in the locker room rich cannon here
on the rich eisenhower let's get to the
here and now
i'll ask this point blank uh rich as we
get set to see gruden on the sideline
tonight for the raiders
are you the only quarterback he ever
liked
i don't know that he liked me john can
be hard on quarterbacks and
you know i i think he's he's a
perfectionist actually one thing i
that we got along so well i realized how
hard he worked to put together a game
plan for me he wanted nothing but
the best for me to succeed and have
success on our team to win and
and so when you put in that same effort
and energy and have the same passion i
think then
you know things work i think derek is on
his way i mean rich i really think he's
had a good year i mean he's got a lot of
young players around the receiver
position
josh jacobs is going to be a star but he
hasn't been healthy they've had injuries
well in the offensive line
i think their biggest achilles heels are
defense i mean in order to be a good
defense in this league
you have to have pass rushers and cover
corners
and the raiders just don't have enough
of them and they give up way too many
points defensively
if you're the raiders you got to score
35 points each week to have a chance to
win
and that's just too tough right now well
the good news is long term is there's
another philly guy who knows the
who knows this very same thing in
mayhawk who's the one who's shopping for
the groceries there
the unfortunate thing is is they got you
know they switched defensive
coordinators
even though it's rod marinelli coming in
uh in a short week
i mean that's tonight with justin
herbert
coming in have you had herbert yet this
year have you seen his
in front of you more herbert games than
anyone
and you know at the networks i think
we've probably done
five games of his i really this kid is
going to be a superstar
i mean he's got you know he was a
three-time academic all-american
rich at oregon his brother his brother
is a first-year
medical student at columbia university
uh he is a really bright kid he didn't
have the benefit of an all-season like
you know obviously
nobody did but it really hurts young
players and young quarterbacks
it's as if he never even needed it he
just he just picked up the system very
quickly
you i think the thing that's been so
oppressed impressive with him
is just the consistency which we don't
see from young players
and young quarterbacks he's going out
there every week and put his team in a
position to have a chance to win now
if anthony lynn can stay out of the way
and and and manage the games better i
mean honestly it's been a
it's been a it's just a train wreck what
they've done late in the half and late
in games with
with uh you know game management
decisions but it
but he's going to be a really good
player i mean he can make all the throws
he's six foot six he's 237 pounds he's
athletic he can run around he can extend
plays he's the real deal
rich gannon here on the rich eisen show
so the best team you've seen in front of
you
i'm not i'm not familiar with every game
that you've called this year but which
is the best team that you've seen in
person
rich well i i i think pittsburgh
you know they've bumped that a little
bump in the road the last two weeks i
think they'll get things back on track i
think the chiefs right now the best team
in the in the afc maybe in professional
football i mean it's the
homes factor rich i mean three
interceptions last week
uh you know they they turned the ball
over four times
uh eight penalties he was sacked three
times they still had four
448 yards of offense he scored 33 points
i mean
even on a bad day they're just so hard
to beat because of him
i mean i've covered a lot of great
quarterbacks aaron rodgers is one of
them
this guy has a lot of the same qualities
and attributes when you look at arm
talent and
feet and quickness and extended you know
but just all the qualities that you love
at the position
and the great thing about mahomes he's
got some humility to him
you know it's he he's so good in the
locker room with his teammates
he accepts responsibility when things
don't go well um
this kid is already a superstar and he's
well on his way to being one of the best
ever a buddy of mine
uh told me um you know when he was
watching my homes the other day
that people in the room were just saying
how
easy football looks for him and we know
it's not easy but it just does
look so simple now obviously the
weaponry and the coaching
has a lot to do with that but i mean if
you put
if you if you rush him up the middle
he'll just backpedal 10 yards right
uh if you if you try and come around the
edge maybe he'll just you know escape it
he'll he'll get out the gate somehow
and then you've got um a a receiving
core
that is headlined by tyreek hill who's a
superstar in this league now
and we had dk metcalf earlier on in the
show rich
but he's the leading receiver in the nfl
the leading pass catcher in the nfl
is their tight end travis kelsey it's
insane
it's insane i think you hit the nail on
the head rich i think he's got
the best tight end football he's got one
of the best receivers in football if
there's a team that has the ability to
run the ball when they want to
and maybe the best play caller in
football and andy reid who doesn't get
enough credit for
you know what he does uh on the
offensive side of the ball with eric the
enemy
they come up with creative packages
every week for for to attack a defense
and
stretch the field they make it they make
you defend the entire field
not just vertically but horizontally i
mean every inch of the field and the
quarterback as you said
i mean honestly i played the position
for 17 years
i was a league mvp he went to four pro
bowls but this guy honestly
you're right he makes it look so easy
and it's not i mean
it's not that easy and yet he goes out
there every week and throws for 350
yards and three or four touchdowns and
i mean when he throws an interception
it's like uh you know it's everyone's
shell shocked
i mean his his ability to take care of
the football to see the field to make
great decisions
i mean everything just seems to slow
down i've talked to a number of
defensive coordinators and nobody
you know you say well that's you know
keep them in the pocket set the edge
force them to function as a pocket
passer don't look don't let them extend
yeah okay okay we'll do all that i mean
you know you know i just remember
when talking to some really good coaches
when they talked about defending peyton
manning and tom brady now they don't
have the mobility that this
this guy has but they always said if you
can rush four and drop
seven in the coverage and you can get
pressure with your front four
right that's your best chance and i
really believe that's the same thing
with my homes you look at the 49ers last
year
in the super bowl i mean if you can
you've got a good defensive line and you
can rush
for and affect himself and speed him up
some that's your best chance well that's
the way that obviously the giants beat
uh the undefeated patriots in that super
bowl just
strahan and tuck and oc and another set
of hands in the dirt and you maybe
you you swap them out for some fresh
rushers and just rush four and
and and get the pressure up up the
middle and you can try and beat them and
we'll see who who can actually do that
this year i got uh rich gannon here on
the rich eisen show
brady um you know uh 43 plus
and breeze 40 plus i mean you were like
a spring chicken now that you take a
look at it when you were
an mvp and you've got rivers this week
he's 39.
uh put put brady and rivers in the same
basket here is two guys who are
are uh in the same i guess age group tax
bracket
if you will uh not nearly as decorated
in their careers but
uh in new offenses this year you're
seeing philip this weekend and you're
looking at brady right now
in tampa through um 14 weeks of football
uh is rivers hitting a stride and
brady's still not comfortable how do you
see it rich gannon
here i think the river situation going
to
indy was a better fit obviously he had
spent time with frank wright frank
newman from their time together with the
chargers
he's playing behind a much better
offensive line rich maybe the best
offense lions ever played with when
they're healthy
he's gonna he's on pace to have the
fewest number of sacks that he's ever
taken in his career i think it's 15
he's on pace for he's got a more
experienced
uh and a better play caller than he had
a year ago who understands the
importance of the running game
especially with the 39 year old
quarterback who
lacks mobility and he's getting the ball
out quick unlike last year where they're
you know
holding the ball trying to push the ball
down the field i mean this year it's
about the short the intermediate passing
game a lot of first down throws
a lot of play action game you're seeing
philip under center a little bit more
than we had earlier in the season
and you know now you've got jonathan
taylor who you know had a
season-high rushing performance last
week again
the raiders so uh i think that bodes
well for them
in terms of brady you know i've talked
to some people down there there's just
there's something that's not they're
just not firing on all cylinders and i
think it's
you know you got bruce involved you got
brian leftwich involved
brady is used to doing it a certain way
and i always felt like this was going to
be the challenge you know
tom had been in one system for 20 years
think about it when he first started
with the patriots he had charlie weiss
when charlie white left bill was smart
enough to know hey look we're not going
to bring in someone from the outside
we're going to promote someone from
within so he promoted a guy a receiver's
coach hardly anyone ever knew
in josh mcdaniels well then when josh
left they promoted another guy that
hardly anyone ever knew
bill o'brien and then when bill was
getting ready to leave they brought back
josh so
all he ever knew was that same system
the same terminology the same verbiage
same footwork and and and they
surrounded him
the cast of characters around him
changed but the system never did and now
he goes to
tampa bay where they're trying to work
with him and work with his system but
bruce has got some concepts he likes
and so it's just for whatever reason and
and i think the other the other thing
that you're not hearing is
i just think brady's used to things
being done a certain way
attention to detail discipline structure
and not saying that bruce isn't that way
but it's probably not as tight it's
probably not as
disciplined and so tom is probably
having to to walk over to the receivers
during practice and
and coach them up a little bit talk to
the backs whereas he never had to do
that
i mean all those assistant coaches in
new england had been there forever
and they all knew it was supposed to be
done a certain way and they all had an
answer to bill
and my sense is as things aren't as
dialed in as he wants him to be
as he needs him to be on sunday and
that's had an effect on his performance
before i let you go rich gannon um
before i let you go here
uh i would like to unpin uh your
reference to mike mcarthur earlier in
this conversation saying that he helped
unlock your career in a way when he was
your quarterback coach way back in the
day in kansas city prior to your days
with the raiders now he's getting his
second crack at being a head coach in
this league after
a remarkable run in green bay
and the narrative involving mike this
season
from unnamed players saying the coaching
staff is without a clue
and that the defensive coordinator and
mike nolan
uh does not have the troops clearly on
the same page for this head coach who
has made some
you know head-scratching decisions i
know you mentioned anthony lynn earlier
today making some decisions that puts
his team behind the eight ball uh there
there's just been a lot to be desired in
his first year in
in dallas what do you think is going on
there
well rich i know you know him well and i
know you have great respect for his body
of work yes do i
and i really believe that mike will get
it turned around i feel awful for him no
one works harder
it's it's important to him to get the
thing right we can't make excuses i mean
not having dac
is a huge issue the injuries they've had
along the offensive line but look
everyone
nobody cares about that that they only
care about is is the product on the
field
and it's been it's not been to their
standard and
i think there'll be some changes i don't
think there's any question i i i
as much as i like mike he's fiercely
loyal to his people
and mike nolan gave him an opportunity
with the 49ers if you'll remember back
yes
nolan hired mike as his coordinator mike
was there one year he had alex smith and
then he left
and went on to coach the green bay
packers and
i think he hired mike gave him an
opportunity i don't think it's worked
out
and i really believe that that'll be the
first change i think there'll be a
defensive coordinator change i think
there'll be some staff changes
but mike's got to look himself in the
mirror and said look i hired these
people
and we've made some bad decisions we
made some poor decisions on game day
and a lot has to change i think it will
it's been an upside
upside down crazy division how about the
washington football club and alex smith
i mean
amazing who would have thought but
anyway i i think there'll be some
changes
uh and i think mike eventually will get
it straightened out he's too good of a
football coach
rich not to uh not to make it work in
dallas yeah i mean washington football
team's been amazing and alex smith what
a story i mean
holy crap what a story rich for him to
be doing
i get one of those 50 votes i think you
do as well rich and honestly
uh it's a slam dunk i think the moment
he stepped onto the field
for the first time there's your comeback
player of the year and now you look at
what he's done
and had he not gotten hurt washington
would have made the playoffs a couple
years ago i mean
he he's a great football player he
doesn't get enough credit for the job
he did in san francisco the job he did
in kansas city the job he did with
patrick mahomes you talked to patrick
mahomes
you talked to andy reid about the impact
and the influence he's made on mahomes
his career
because he learned and watched a pro do
it and that that was so important but
anyway i i think the world of alex smith
it makes me nervous rich every time he
steps on the field i get hurt again
me too but that went out the window
really when the first
the first sack he took when he returned
was
aaron donald on his back and he he
walked aaron donald by
about a yard or two before he finally
went down and
i saw that i'm like oh my gosh he's that
that's the best first hit he could have
taken and gotten up from
imagine no rich i mean we all you know
we all have uh
skin in the game to some extent but
could you imagine how his wife feels
every time
oh my gosh how about the orthopedic
surgeon
how about the plastic surgeon everyone
who worked on him he had a he had a
right he had a an army of doctors they
they're watching this game with great
interest
obviously they're huge fans but they got
to be just scared to death every time
the guy takes a sack
i know rich oh my gosh hey this has been
a great conversation let's do this
uh more often uh maybe we'll get you
back on it
in the playoffs enough i can't thank you
enough for the for the work that you do
on behalf of the national football
league you've been amazing and
you've been a you've been a great mentor
to a lot of people like myself who come
into the profession
that are very green and that your
patience your professionalism your
expertise and your attention to detail
really rubs off and so i just want to
thank you man i hope you guys have a
great holiday
you too rich thanks for the compliment
thanks for the call i look forward to
hearing you
uh on cbs with the colts and the texans
in week 15. rich gannon right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here